Macaulay Culkin is speaking out against
drug addiction rumors in a rare
interview with the Guardian the former
child star opened up about the rumors
that have plagued most of his adult life
telling the website quote no I was not
pounding six grand of heroin every month
or whatever the thing that bugged me was
tabloids wrapping it all in this weird
guise of concern no you're trying to
shift papers he also says the public was
not necessarily right to worry about him
after photos surfaced in 2012 of his
shockingly slim figure this place is
starting to look like Hollywood back in
April the 35 year old actor told vulture
he is essentially retired when it comes
to the amount of attention he receives
from the paparazzi
he tells The Guardian quote I don't
think I'm worthy of that though he does
appear in a new commercial for compare
the market it's me Macaulay he also says
he's never had a problem admitting he
doesn't have any acting gigs lined up
saying maybe I'll take the next year off
if I knew what I wanted to do I'd be
writing it myself we're still hoping for
another home alone ah
you